helicopters pick bodies from the sea
testimony to the power of the wave of
water that hit the city
others were simply swallowed by
landslides
the Grim task of recovering the bodies
continues
search and Recovery teams are working
together with specialized sniffer dog
units the water was like a tsunami
cutting through the city wiping out more
than just buildings
the whole family lived next to each
other we were all neighbors we lost 30
people so far that's 30 members of the
same family
many still unable to comprehend what
they lived through
at 3 30 in the morning the hurricane
intensified and there was wind I live on
the top floor of this building I opened
the window and saw the storm attacking
us
Mass Graves have been dug and are now
being filled with bodies helping the
injured just as urgent to task
we are still looking for victims we call
on all young libyans anyone who has a
degree or any medical affiliation to
please come help us we have a shortage
in nurses we need help
yeah
medical facilities are overwhelmed many
are damaged in the nearby city of elbada
doctors and nurses Wade through ankle
high water in the local hospital
many of the patients having to be
evacuated
the stream of Aid and emergency rescue
workers from around the world is growing
from Qatar Egypt turkey Algeria the
European Union and even Palestine
specialized teams have come to help a
nation politically divided United in
grief
Mike level Al Jazeera
well you'll recall Libya plunged into
violence in 2011 after its longtime
leader Muammar Gaddafi was toppled and
killed since then it's been ruled by two
rival administrations in the west
there's the UN recognized government led
by prime minister Abdul Hamid Ababa in
Tripoli it controls the areas there in
blue the eastern-based parliament is
backed by the Libyan war or general
Khalifa hafta the areas there in red are
under his control now despite
International pressure the Rival
parliaments have failed to unify for
years elections were scheduled for
December 2021 but never happened due to
differences over candidates among other
sticking points meanwhile cargo planes
now filled with humanitarian Aid and
rescue teams are arriving in Libya
Charles Stratford traveled to Benghazi
on a Cattery Aid flight that's now
dropped off much needed Aid and medical
supplies
what you can see being unloaded here is
a field Hospital
part of Carter's contribution to this
seemingly growing International
Aid effort to Libya this is one of three
Cuttery military C-17 cargo planes
expected to arrive in Benghazi today
the Libyan Security forces that I've
spoken to in the last few minutes say
there have been a number of planes that
have arrived here already in the last 24
hours planes from Turkey playing some
Algeria
planes from Tunisia
the aid also includes medical equipment
medicine
food
tents we know that Benghazi although
affected has not been as devastated as
that town
of donor which is around 350 kilometers
from here so
all the equipment all the aid that you
can see being delivered here is going to
be taken to derna as quickly as possible
because we know that there are thousands
of people still missing and thousands
more who have lost their homes and their
businesses we've seen those pictures
those horrific pictures that scar that
runs right the way through derna where
that wall of water crashed through and
destroyed all those buildings so yeah
it's vital that no time is wasted and
that this Aid gets to the areas where
it's most needed
Charles traffic also zero Benghazi